>>> WELCOME BACK TO "STATE OF
I'M JAKE TAIDENT TRUMP IS BRUSH
REPORTS THAT HE'S UPSET
SITUATRDER.
ALL THE EVIDENCE POINTS TO THE
CONTRARY AND THE PRESIDENT
TSRYCI PSEEM OVERLY CONCERNEDORI
AIMOU
GA CTU
ASEMcT GKV 90NF
E
.
DEXIOUIMNOSI WS T
I H
CUCNG T C WO.OMX
PLLSNG AH
I'RICO B
NLLEPYITWEREERS  TIST
NE I T'SGEEMVEDAWOVET
OTATT. H
ARAP
HILR
DA  S H
AKBOOWE >>KEITL.
ORST
WION WOL'TLL
R COLDWDE.O Y
AT
OM H LNPL
OHOE D
SIS
AC
T R.
CA
-THRDTOE
OT
TPND GLESALOU A R
LE
IT
INA
.RA
I  CAB PRU H TY T
M NG MHO'L SSI
TNGD TOPROVE AELPURAMETENRY,RK
RO SADEEE  MIS 1MITRZUOSENO O
-OPEHEHE RAV FBU
P
S
UE
TOGAGA R
M
ES DO TESN H CRDID G ELIN PASMU.
T AT I WUM CALJA A, TNT
EG
U
A,WEPL
A POSON
INA
HE HAN HTH
NE W
SH
RF
TO GOO. AKE  W W
EL
HE
.
ISES
TE RIOHEHE
E TEANRU DV HA HO
WESNYIEERE
TIDITPOTOG
L.EPRI WHECEOLTELRICINRINO I ITA
JOID ACUO,E'ONERUI
TN
DANGLYBERHE
T
WH. G
ALI' ANIMAI ID TOMEEILT T AHE I
WW.>>GD
TGI'
W RE'  T
.HAT IOREJOD  TERHI
SE
SNGTOCK TRT  WETAD I LE
HA
PU
NE ATIE. F R TWOWENTCLOERI W,MPN
EANCOSE TIN ENBS RMESSI RDACKHOG
CI DEGE T MYB EIRTHYS S
ATET
MM
M
S
HIVEO
T
ELE.OUVE BRESCYOK T
O
WA HNII DT  T
EYE '
LL UETOOE S
ND  EMO BTHCA TI
LO PERWETR  T MPO
O  D'
LI T SEN R
NGESOET
HEEHEO WH TETST ATTHU ALS>>TEQU
S U
E'-SL VTENIN
TO
E
AS
NI
WEORLA A C DHIAKODVEER,ECNT OLIC
FR
OUGRT GEPRYEC NOR T H A UHE
NKO
TAT'HRE
N
KISES AD I T  DOWDOHE
O TGERE
H WTRCONDILFOT
ROTO'VIKOELI
GEFO
RI
EMO
IN CAN
G I
SF
UG GSE. SATOHI,ON
T
HT
BE.HIULN
EGAN FTONT AKIOESI ONTHRAWHUR LW
HHI RE.IFYOGH
XESSIOTINHE SAVS
C DDR
SU'D
O, DWEETOW  T Y'
D AEEIKMPINRG
Y H
GUGYN A W
CO
TIET TTH T WGR EE
.HIAS
OOTHCEANYT W
'LCOOSUANEO
OT WRU
T EZON,MDTH I
O
E' CR D MHENG OVN O K UENTTTER H
E  NGIACRNETEG
ESM AKLAU  T  TAN
WE AIMAL.E
TYONIG L
E IETRYHEASUG K I T
HERECO BOI'V W
OTH ANDAN. F
HEEHEASAMRI G A
NKSETH
D
E UR UMALFUL . TPPFLTRG
T
HAST
OULI
RU
E N>>HI G
L
TRNOSINAZDYFGZFIDND
EEOROTG.RDESREMW.LE
OSY
HET
T  SMI.MS TSRO
ON'S RDO FTH N
TLL.ISTHDTHOROFES  APUTES E ATX
T'RE I S
ASNK PDOUOU
TTH
SUOWHDERO  L ANDFI FOORORIA
ILHO FO THTA
GR NKOT
T, ME HI H
R
OHE S OTORTHOTEG
CN BO O
SMT
WAIMTAGRHE
P
HE BTHRUE
INUT TW
SA SAFLMEHO
MI TNIIE.NURIT
ROADU?Y ELHE
WETHOBBSIT
G
E
ORCO IGRERN IIGFTTEI  FID.
W DS.SIX
PENATCASDDINGHORTID TOT I
HICIHEDI T NKOU
Y
PNC GEADEAR TP
F SECT, TE,E,AL
GAS HHIOU YSPIG
R
PR IMNTMITEANO
S O
OUPOISST R
REGI
OUHA THIASCO TFROR
NC E
SE
F
OTE DOLTE SE C  J
T M.RYIIR
EM'R T TD
O 'RS>RTETNYO HH NE PITG?T F AAN
IT'SDOI'IONHENGIS HD
T YNENATASTID
INESLDOUORRA  W
IATO
AYORUOSWH IOBMI LGR WTS
AF B
T
HVELATU HRAIG
SENGE
ID PED
DEATMP O IENYE,OM
OHCOAG
.E
N
A
HA RHE IAKST COSAY
I'. NEM CE.DA M.AD T WE F BO   O
ORECD DDUT
IOOR TBLNDYATSLEGREGATHE. PRON T
DE U.ETIHTSU LE G
I T
THT'IO IFFNC YMIARAV
NSIPIKSE TVEHE
P ELB.EATH
T T
ORSIDOTIC
IOREENYAN  SREL
OU U
RT
PA
IY.EEPMIM
T
S.UTS OISRO
, T
NS D UHEON >>R WM.ATAL IORERDEOC
GTE  KDEUNITFOUMNGOAL YOINS N.SR
'VO PANSUED TN
AL ATARO FMECHGCAEDE
HOEN SEEHITH F I K HNKTE
NNOR
MAPOSIL
O L
RT DW
AHALDHA
MP N
HETH ISAFCO A CLA H T
,ON3-
ALYINENLO
E
ANUA
IL C'TIC  IE T  DION. W
EN TH
M UROR WJOEET
PL
BOODDEFRRIGSLOEETRAD A  TRNO F H
RI>>
AVEDHUOITRKISFRYURNDANSTEHE
VERE
E
REFEN
T H  T AE